-Our next guest
is a Tony-nominated
and Emmy Award-winning actress
you know from her work
in Broadway's
"Wicked" and "Dreamgirls,"
as well as shows like
"Ray Donovan" and "Moesha."
She stars
in "Abbott Elementary,"
which airs Wednesday nights
on ABC.
Let's take a look.
-Uh, what I'm seeing here is,
you guys just
failed to pay attention
to what was happening.
You have absolutely no case.
And, in fact, according to this,
you might each owe
Legendary Chargers, yeah,
$200 for crew fees.
-For what?
-I don't --
-Let them try to get the money.
-So you are saying
that we're just gonna have to
see this commercial forever,
and there's no way
we can get it off the air?
-You could pay for Hulu
without commercials.
Mm-hmm.
-Please welcome to the show
the one, the only
Sheryl Lee Ralph, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome, Sheryl!
I am so happy to see you.
I knew -- the last time
I saw you was at the Emmys.
We talked before the show
about how you were coming on.
We did not know that our paths
were going to cross again...
-That's right.
-...over the course
of the evening,
which is Amy Poehler and I
presented the Emmy
for your category,
and we were lucky enough to be
onstage when you came up.
-Look at you.
-I was very happy for you.
-Yes, very handsome.
-I was very happy.
I was also very happy that you
showed up because, Sheryl,
you were so surprised you won,
you sat in your chair
for a long time.
-I did.
[ Laughter ]
Seth, when they called my name,
it was like everything
just turned to mush,
and I was in some surreal place.
And I was like,
"Is this really happening?
Did they really
just call my name?"
And then I could hear
Quinta and Tyler say, "Get up!"
[ Laughter ]
-Well,
I love this photo 'cause, one,
you can see
how happy everyone is,
and, two, you can see that
you really...
[ Laughter ]
Now, be honest.
Did you have any -- so did you
just go into it thinking,
"Oh, this is an honor
to be nominated,
but I won't be up there
accepting an award tonight?"
-That is absolutely it.
I mean, you spend your career,
you do the good work.
You don't think about the fact
that, "Oh, I'm gonna get this,
or I'm gonna get that,"
or whatever.
It would be nice,
but you really do the good work.
So when Oprah got up
on that stage and said,
"Only 1 in 3,000 people
will ever have one of these,
and you all are probably
not one of them"...
[ Laughter ]
...I was like, "Okay.
She set the bar."
But then they called my name,
and it was like my whole career
went in front of me.
And I was like, "Oh, my God.
I'm 1 in 3,000!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And then, I have heard since
that you got some, you know --
I believe Oprah herself
reached out after the fact.
The Vice President reached out.
-It's all true.
-You played Deena Jones
on Broadway in "Dreamgirls."
-Yes.
-And someone else played
the same role in cinema,
reached out to you.
-Yes, baby.
Beyoncé sent me flowers!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let me tell you.
That right there,
that's a very nice note
to get from Beyoncé.
That one goes
right in the scrapbook.
-Yes, it does.
Yes, it does.
And then I got the nice phone
call from the Vice President.
And I was like,
"Kamala, we did it!
Kamala, we did it!"
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly.
It's full circle.
-Absolutely.
-Obviously,
you've been on stage.
You've been in film
and television.
"Abbott Elementary"
is a wonderful show.
I guess it's a slightly
different style for you
because it is this
mockumentary style.
Did you find it --
Did you step right into it?
Did you have to learn it?
Because it seems so natural
watching you do it.
-It's a bit of a learning curve.
I mean,
the fact that the cameras --
of course you know
the cameras are there.
But the cameras are,
like, there.
And the choreography,
they're, like, there.
There were parts of me I did not
know people were seeing,
and I was like,
"I'm getting to the gym."
[ Laughter ]
-That's how they get you.
I was like, "Oh, my God!"
But it was all right, you know.
We had a good time.
And I love our camera crew.
They literally
have their own choreography.
They have these little
squeegee stools
that they work on, and they can
spin around and do crazy things,
and they're just so good.
They're like a part of the cast,
in a weird way.
-The response to this show
has been phenomenal
across all walks of life.
But one of the things
I keep hearing that must be
so rewarding for everybody
involved in the show
is how much teachers love it.
Do you just hear constantly
from people
in the teaching profession?
-I constantly hear from
all kinds of educators --
teachers, principals, everybody.
But especially
the teachers saying,
"Finally, we are not
the butt of the joke.
We are the heart of the show."
-Yeah.
-And it's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
And it's just --
it's just so wonderful
to hear from them,
and when they say things
to you like, "I feel seen.
I feel understood,"
and I'm like,
"Honeys, everybody got a feeling
for what you all go through
through the pandemic."
-Yeah.
-All those people
sending those messages,
"I had no idea my child
was so bad!"
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, my God!
I didn't know
this is what you go through!
I'm sorry I didn't show up
to the parent-teacher meeting!"
All of that.
But I know, finally,
they know that we understand.
And honest to God, teachers
really deserve much more.
They deserve more respect,
more pay,
more of everything
in the classroom.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Absolutely.
Your --
Your father was an educator.
-Yes.
-Did you try to borrow anything
in your character from the way
your father taught?
-My dad is my lifelong angel.
He was a lifelong learner.
In fact,
when I hit that center stage,
and I was about to ready
to just break down,
I could hear my father say,
"Don't you dare.
This is your moment.
Make sure
they know who you are."
[ Laughter ]
I could hear him.
But for Barbara Howard,
I really, really lean
into my Auntie Carolyn,
who was a reluctant teacher
turned blue-ribbon principal
who actually had
the Queen of England
at her school twice because
she dared to ask her to come.
-Oh, man, that's amazing.
And to come back.
-How about that?
-Yeah.
And sip that tea.
I was like,
"Yes, Auntie Carolyn!
You go, Bunker Hill.
She did that."
-We talked about your
relationship with the stage.
This is very exciting.
You're producing a play
that's, I believe, starting --
is it starting previews
in a couple weeks?
-It's starting previews
in 11 days
in the new
James Earl Jones Theatre.
-Well, that's fantastic.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know this is a --
this is a play
by a very prolific playwright
who we might not know.
But what's really impressive is
how long she's been doing this.
-You know what?
I tell people,
"If you don't make it at 20,
you can make it at 30.
You can make it at 40.
You can make it at 50.
You can make it at 60!"
Well, the writer of this play,
"The Ohio State Murders,"
Ms. Kennedy,
she is 91 years old.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So don't you ever,
ever give up on your dreams.
She's 91 years old.
I'm like, "You go, girl."
Of course
I got to be a part of this.
And Audra McDonald, too.
And directed by Kenny Leon.
I'm like, "Come on.
We got to get halfway to EGOT.
At least halfway."
-Yeah.
Just don't try to do it
all in one year.
-There you go.
But one never knows.
-You could be the first EGOT
in one calendar year.
-How about that?
That would be good.
-That would be not bad.
-'22 has been a very good year.
-Well, maybe you'll grab the G
on your new Christmas song.
What is the title
of your new Christmas song?
-"Sleigh."
-"Sleigh"?
-Okay.
But not S-L-A-Y.
-No.
S-L-E-I-G-H.
-Okay.
-But it all depends
on how you say it,
because we are going to slay.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I've never heard
Santa say it like that.
[ Laughter ]
He's never said it like that.
Well, I'm very excited
to hear that.
And, man, what an honor
just to see you again.
-Oh, thank you.
-Please come back soon.
Everyone,
that's Sheryl Lee Ralph.
"Abbott Elementary,"
Wednesdays at 9:00 p.m., on ABC.
We'll be right back
with Sohla El-Waylly.